when it comes to design and decoration
it feels extremely tricky and dangerous
to accuse anyone of having bad taste or
to pride oneself on having good taste
the official story is that anything goes
and no one knows what's good or bad
anyway but that seems too easy and
lacking in ambition progress can in fact
be made on this important issue if we
try to understand what psychological
mechanisms govern the business of taste
in the first place why do we have the
taste we have why we attracted or
repelled by certain sorts of styles the
best way to interpret this is via a
theory of compensation we're all a bit
unbalanced inside and get attracted to
styles in the world but promised to
compensate us for the things that we're
lacking within
so for example people who feel chaotic
undisciplined and cluttered inside are
liable to be very drawn to interior sat
a serene pure and poised equally people
who are very exposed to an oppressed by
the brutal tempo of modern life with its
excessive brutality precision and
technological wall are likely to be
drawn to styles that speak of the rustic
the natural and the cozily shabby now
that might be an explanation for taste
but what about bad taste
what singles out instances of bad taste
is excess in some direction or another
bad taste is a massive overcompensation
which has been generated by a sharp
shortfall in some area or another it's a
response to a psychological physical
trauma so for example the Russians and
the Saudis have over the years developed
a reputation for spectacularly bad as in
Gordian over-the-top taste a pumped-up
version of Versailles in Riyadh or
Moscow this isn't in a sense surprising
a century of extreme deprivation under
communism and an eternity of eking out a
living in the barren deserts of Saudi
Arabia have created understandably
desperate desires for compensation which
have evidently rather Belva shot their
mark or think of sentimental bad taste
the kind where there are gnomes in the
front gardens and gaudy and sickly sweet
trinkets inside this is a style
frequently favored by the less well-off
in society people whose working lives
are humiliating back-breaking and the
very opposite of welcoming or tender it
should be no wonder that these
unfortunates might therefore be in the
mood for something counterbalancing ly
sweet at home in every instance of bad
taste we're looking at the overeager
embracing of a good quality like
sweetness freedom fun or prosperity that
was once in a very short supply bad
taste often sickens people but once one
understands its origins it starts to
seem unduly harsh to judge like this we
can all understand that if a person is
starving they might eagerly eat things
which in less desperate situations
they'll obviously reject and that in
their desperation their manners might
take a box
it's not at all prissy but we never
blame them because we know why they're
stuffing themselves with such haste we
should apply similar tact when
confronted with unfortunate tastes in
design what's bad in bad taste isn't the
person but the prior trauma which
they're seeking to compensate for
through their deck or there's no point
in mocking or offering lectures about
art history the problem isn't a lack of
information it's a trauma created by a
badly broken unbalanced world the
solution to bad taste is therefore
political good taste comes about when
people feel appreciated when there's
enough to go around and when there's an
economy which doesn't routinely
humiliate in a base its workers to make
good taste more widespread what matters
above all our efforts to diminish the
desperate lives in which lapses of taste
invariably have their origins
you
you